did we mention that Marie Osmond is yeah
I didn't hear that
you didn't hear that she's purple socks
are at the table ar but were noticeably
Marie Osmond is Marie and her brother
Donnie captivated audiences for more
than five decades including in this very
first episode of their own remember it
well where he went on to co-found the
Children's Miracle Network Hospitals
helping it raise more than seven billion
with Abbey dollars she also became
exists a successful entrepreneur on QVC
and danced her way across television on
Dancing with the Stars Dancing with the
Stars family she joined the talk for its
tenth season which premiered last Monday
I would be there right now but I am
spending my second Monday with you all
of it at this table
well you had co-hosted 4:40 time you had
cozy the show great times yeah I and
they finally offered it to you would you
a full time she did you have to think
about it
well I was asked by the head of the
daytime television and I looked at her
and I said yes but I love these ladies
they are so much fun people their
sisters they are well it there's I don't
have a sister and this is kind of like
the right you don't know I don't know so
you have all these female opinions I'm
like well this is a smart table no
offense guys yeah it's just a different
thing I grew up with men and how many
brothers did you do you have I have
eight eight brothers yeah and I have
eight children I have four boys and four
girls but I don't know it's just a
different phase of life I love the show
because it's upbeat and it's fun they
are all a hoot and I love each one of
them but it this is what happened in
your first week though because you're
known for sharing you've talked about
having two deaf brothers you've talked
about feeling responsible for your
mother's car accident you've talked
about going back to work after your
son's funeral
I mean you you really opened up already
in the first week you're okay clearly
was sharing your life well I think
that's one of the things you have to
realize when you step up to that table I
don't believe in airing dirty laundry I
don't think that's necessary but if you
can do something that can help somebody
else or you know help them get through
something
and I maybe it's that sisterhood thing
sharing postpartum depression yes I was
the first female to actually celebrity
to actually talk about it and I don't
know I just I felt that there's so much
shame around things when really it's
just the human experience that we all go
through and I don't care if you're a
celebrity or if you know you're a makeup
artist or if whatever you do for a
living we all go through this thing
called life
yeah social media now though there's so
much more feedback both good and bad
that well I think that there's always
positive and everything and you can
always find the negative and everything
the biggest thing I think for children
is that they want to live an illusion
and they see other people's illusions
and they think that's reality and it's
really not and so I think you have to be
very careful with that I know my
youngest just turned 17 17 how old is
your oldest older than me her age range
goes from 17 to what say 36 because
Marie has 10 grandchildren I just want
one Oh Donny has 10 ok I've showed you
attend so you have 8 so 8 grandchildren
ah ah really I can't wait till I have
one what are your grandchildren call you
grandma grandma yeah I look like grandma
my like being called grandma I do I love
it my mom was the best grandma uh-huh
and there's just something as my one she
calls me up grandma
I'm like yeah anything you want they're
just they're just the love of my life
and guess part is you get to send them
home if they have a dirty diaper yeah
you don't have to raise them you just
love them you've been living in Las
Vegas for 11 years
yeah hard to raise kids in Las Vegas I
think people who spent the weekend there
my face well you don't take him to the
strip no there's a very big family
community there yeah and I think Selena
and I were the only two that actually
lived there but no they they have some
really wonderful schools and you just
have to make sure they're in the right
schools and but my kids did well I
raised my four older outside of Vegas
and my four younger ones were raised in
Vegas and you and Donnie had the longest
selling show the Big Show's right 11
year but he was bigger than Celine show
well and I just heard of this actually
Gail so Caesars just gave us the key to
the honor
uh-huh which is better than the key to
the city I just want it to go into the
box where they keep all the cash no but
they said that we have we will have done
more shows when we finish in November
then Celine and Elvis combined all right
now you are on okay know if you're on
the talk that's for the CBS cell phone I
love it to have you here